got a great recommendation for you today
I just finished reading the 2013 book
the circle by David Eggers the concept
is basically of a super powerful
all-encompassing internet type silicon
valley company whether it's like a
Google esque company or a facebook s
company whatever the case may be the
book is the story lines are sort of
obvious and self-evident in many ways
and the symbolism is really pretty
straightforward and easy to understand
but it's still a really entertaining and
sort of interesting look at what could
be a slightly more dystopian future in
thinking about these types of companies
that get involved in so many different
areas of our lives and more importantly
get access to more and more of our
day-to-day habits and preferences when
it comes to buying and society and
culture and friends etc so i recommend
it it's a pretty quick read it's very
very entertaining again the book is
called the circle by dave eggers and i
just finished it and i recommend that
you check it out if you read it send me
your thoughts about it you can of course
check out all of my recommendations
including documentaries TV shows movies
books etc at david pakman.com slash
recommendations and I don't know Pat I
think this is one that you might enjoy
if you read it I'm going to have to pick
this one up I said yeah well you can
borrow my copy if you want and sometimes
when people say that to me I'm like yeah
sure sometimes and then you never return
that right i return it i just never read
it and then i have to pretend that i
read it which is a whole awkward thing
don't do that pat if you if i'll let you
borrow it but i want to be sure that you
actually will read it okay david
pakman.com slash recommendations we got
a big show for you today we'll take some
phone calls next remember that i'm on
twitter at d pakman send me your
thoughts about whatever is on your mind
politically there